[Applause]
suppose suppose ladies and gentlemen I
bring to you now black bush President
Bush continues to make this case for an
invasion of Iraq after carefully
examining the region me and my cabinet
agree that that area is definitely right
for regime change all right but if I can
be real about it be real sign real real
real shot kill my father man play that
say where'd he try to kill your
father
[Music]
meanwhile President Bush and British
Prime Minister Tony Blair offered a
spirited explanation for a possible war
with Iraq this nigga very possibly has
weapons of mass destruction I can't
sleep on it not on my watch that's not
how I roll that is serious now if
you want to take my word for launching X
Tony Blair he got a hold of seven
telogen boys what's up Tony we don't
know much about random niggas with
things like that as George so eloquently
put it on I'm with him a hundred percent
of the way we don't know what he hurts
if the United States goes to war with
Iraq will it first have to provide
evidence that Saddam Hussein has weapons
of mass destruction so far the UN has
found nothing but President Bush
counters with this aluminum - gladly -
tell you what the you can do with
an aluminum they don't skate bad I
didn't one say this
the bought some yellow cake
okay in Africa he went to Africa and he
bought yellow cake are you sure yes I'm
sure a bitch ridiculous me jib just
coming back from Africa cradle of
are you sure it was yellow cake
y'all niggas don't believe me I got
yellow cake right here look she don't
drop that no I know what doing it I got
it wrapped up in especially I ain't
robbed bad yeah
hello jump this pray to God no got
this yellow cake right a
sensitive accusation for this
administration is the theory held by
many that the real reason the u.s. is so
interested in toppling Sodom is control
of the oil that Iraq is sitting on what
about people who say you're only
interested in the Middle East for oil
what President Bush met with UN
Secretary General Kofi Annan and made it
clear the US will act even if the UN is
reluctant you win him problem with that
you know what you should do you should
sanction me sanction me with your army
oh wait a minute you don't have
ouch up my sweet sixteen Lange
cuz you gonna need them when you in task
we're selling fake hats I don't do tea
when I see it they got rich
I got a Coalition of the Willing I got
40 nations ready to roll son like who
folks say that like who angling Japan's
sending Playstations thank onea said
they're willing to drop bombs over
Baghdad Afrika Bambaataa the Zulu Nation
not doing this by myself and I'm not
disrespecting that you win even though
they don't got no army go sell some
medicine bitches trying to get that all
uh-huh
the u.s. fired the opening salvo in the
war on Iraq with at least 40 Tomahawk
cruise missiles and precision guided
bombs centering on Baghdad good evening
tonight President George Bush is on
board the aircraft carrier USS Abraham
Lincoln off the California coast it will
be the site of what is essentially his
victory speech in the war against Iraq
Oh what did I say I'm not gloating
but what did I say to that let's say
that we will win it we rocked them
families we wrapped up the second
straight day these hardline Iraqis
protested the American presence here mr.
president when do you think they'll hold
general elections in Iraq damn I
shouldn't call it on his name distract
with things like the war
and stir all real issues gay people are
getting married folks yes
Nantz imagine that two women touching on
each other's titty balls wrestling
gently stroking those nipples so they
get just so stiff and a rat blowing on
pillar men barbecue like I like you too
doll
let's get married man it's crazy what
about your rich it is gross
mr. president mr. president sir how do
you explain the continual upheaval in
Iraq even after the capture of Saddam
Hussein why are you doing this man
I thought she's my black brother why you
ask me questions like that fine I'll ask
you a stupid areas question here's how I
feel about Iraq I feel like you guys
keep trying to distract people with Iraq
when I'm focusing on other things namely
the moon yes I said it the moon can't be
distracted what's going on with the war
or what's wrong with your coming stop
worrying about that I got that
under control lost focus from space
nigga the United States of space as I
stopping at the moon write this down
am a or s mars bitches faxes we are :
boss red rocks yo yo
know something we're not just gonna go
to New Hampshire Tom Harkin we are gonna
go to New York
we're gonna go to Vermont we're gonna
throw the Oregon we're gonna throw the
Pittsburgh in Pennsylvania we're going
to keep cool for spring break
we're gonna go to Montreal we're going
to that Coover I'm going all over the
world and then I'm coming all the way
wiring and easy to take back the White
House
[Applause]
and I will chop that mode by the desk in
half
now grab your secret servers like this
we're gonna hit lovers Hey
they're going scared about better look
at my wife I guess
[Applause]
and then I'm gonna wash up we'll wash up
and Emma be like this yeah
goodnight
[Applause]
he says policy for this administration
and I support the president 92nd well I
think it's important to remember when
you're talking about this issue that
Vice President Cheney has a lesbian
daughter and not only is his daughter
Elizabeth but his mom's illiterate and
his sisters lesbian and his greasy
granny has holes in her panties I
watched the l-word on Showtime yeah
[Applause]
a little break Washington Vermont
[Music]